如果你是上班族講做當沖
但每天只有幾分鐘可以看完
這支影片就是為你拍的
今天我要教你一個方法
叫做開盤跳空法
每天早上9點05分
只需要對一檔股票檢查三個條件
三個都符合
才考慮進場
找一個直接跳過
去上班完全無形同
從頭到尾你需要的時間
大概不是五分鐘
大家好 我是猛卡
當沖實戰八年
教學五年
很多人以為做當沖
一定要從早訂到下午一點班
時間不夠就沒辦法做
今天我想分享一個專門設計給
沒時間盯盤的人用的方法
讓你每天早上只要5分鐘
就能完成今天的判斷
影片最後我會給你一份冷包
三個條件加上進出場的完整流程
整理成一張圖讓你帶走
明天早上9點05分拿出來對照就能使用
記得看到最後收藏起來
在講三個條件之前
先把什麼是跳空說清楚
假設昨天有一檔股票
最後成交價是100塊
今天早上一開盤
直接從103塊開始交易
中間那3塊
昨天根本沒有走過
今天直接跳過去了
這就是跳空
跳空代表今天一開盤
就有人願意用筆
昨天還要高的價格進來買
要撐得住這種開發
通常是很多人
同時願意用更高的價格買進
才能造成這個結果
那為什麼會有人願意用
更高的價格進來買
最常見的是
昨天收盤後
這檔股票傳出了好消息
可能是公司財務數字表現不錯
或是某個政策
某個新聞對這類股票有幫助
這些消息開始在股市裡擴散
有很多人當天晚上
或是今天一早看到
決定今天要買
等到早上9點一開盤
這批人同時湧進來
第一筆成交的金額就直接跳到
比昨天更高的位置
行程跳空
但光是跳空還不夠
你還須確認
這批人是真的在持續買進
還是只是開盤那一瞬間的熱情而已
剛開盤的幾分鐘
股市最混亂
股價可能一回往上
一回往下
方向不太清楚
等到9.05分
你看完了開盤後
真正五分鐘的走勢
就比較能夠知道
開盤買進的這批人
是繼續再買
還是已經開始再賣了
這個資訊比9.1開盤
就直接衝進去買
還要不靠
第一個條件
今天開盤價比昨天最後
成交價高出的幅度
要落在2%到4%之間
開盤價就是每天股市里成交的
第一筆價格
你在看盤軟體上
通常可以直接看到
今天的漲跌幅百分比
你不需要自己算
幅度只要低於兩%
代表跳空的力量有點弱
後面通常走不了多遠
很容易賣忙一場
幅度超過4%
一開盤
太多人衝進來買
接著往往會有另外一批人
趁機想要把之前買的
賣出去
想要快速賺那4%的漲幅
股價很快就會被這些
賣出的力量往下壓
這時候衝進去
馬上看到股票往下走的機會
2%到4%的這個區間買進力到夠強
又不至於大到讓許多人搶著賣
第二個條件
開盤後前5分鐘股價最後要停在相對比較高的位置
在看這個條件之前
先說一下你在看盤軟體上會看到什麼畫面
看盤軟體上的走勢圖是用一根一根的柱子
來呈現股價的變化
每一根柱子代表一段固定時間內的價格走勢
這種柱子在股市裡叫做K棒
接著你可以在看盤軟體上
設定每根K棒代表多長的時間
這裡我們用5分鐘K棒
讓你清楚看到
開盤後每5分鐘的走勢變化
你在走勢圖上
看開盤後的第一根K棒
觀察兩種情形
符合條件K棒大部分是紅色的
最後停在靠近K棒頂端的位置
表示這5分鐘買進的力量
有持續不符合條件
K棒由往上衝
但後來被往下壓回來
最後停在K棒中間甚至下放
上面留了一根有點長的上銀線
這代表國家曾經長到那裡
但被想賣出來的力量給壓了下來
前五分鐘買進的力量已經開始減弱了
記得前五分鐘收在上面
也被壓回來一大截
第三個條件
開盤後前五分鐘的成交量
要達到昨天整天成交量的10%
成交量就是那段時間
你實際完成買賣的股票數量
在看盤軟體下方就可以看到
前五分鐘量太少
代表參與的人不多
你想賣可能沒有人賣
你想賣可能沒有人要買
這時候進出都不順暢
計算方式是
昨天整天成交量乘以0.1
就是你今天要對照的目標數字
記得前五分鐘要先有一成的量
三個條件有個最快的執行方式
照著這個順序做
一檔股票30秒以內就能判斷完
第一步看漲跌幅數字
打開看盤軟體
找到今天這檔股票的漲跌幅百分比
確認有沒有落在
2%到4%之間
這部沒有過
直接跳過
看下一檔
第二部看左視圖上的
第一根K棒形狀
切換到5分K的畫面
看開盤後第一根K棒
確認大部分是紅色
最後有停在靠近頂端的位置
上面沒有一根長上銀線
這部沒過
直接跳過這檔
看下一檔
第三部看成交量
有沒有到昨天的一成
往下看成交量的數字
確認一下前5分鐘的成交量
有沒有達到昨天整天的10%
如果這步也沒過就跳過
要三步都過了
這檔股票才能依照五大訊號的方向進場
如果訊號有多數是呈現做多
那麼買進去之後
有兩件事要馬上設定好
一個是虧損的出場點
一個是獲利的出場點
兩個都是好
你才能真的放心去做其他事情
不用一直盯著盤面
先說虧損的出場點
以我們做這檔線當充為例
我們可以直接往下抓兩檔或是三檔
超過4檔就有點太多了
再說獲利的出場點
你可以提前設定好目標價格
也就是股價漲到哪裡
你就賣出把獲利拿走
新手建議先設定在買金價格的上方
兩檔到4檔之間
我用一個例子就說明
假設你今天買進一檔股票
買進的價格是150元
你的虧損出場點就可以設定
149或是148.5
虧損控制在2到3檔以內
你的獲利出場點
那它就可以設定在
151到152塊之間
長到這裡就賣出
把1000到2000元的獲利拿走
兩個點都設好
接下來你就不需要一直盯著畫面
到點就自動出場
先從能穩定把這一到2000元拿到練起來
等你熟悉的這個節奏
再來討論怎麼把獲利目標往上調
今天教的開盤跳空法
你明天早上就可以試著用了
但很多人第一次用的時候
會遇到一個困難
你知道要找有跳空的標的
但是每天股市裡有幾百檔股票
要怎麼在9.5分之前
快速找到今天值得關注的那幾檔
這個選股流程
我在一場免費的線上直播講座禮
會跟你分享
包括怎麼用一個免費的工具
如何在開盤一分鐘內篩選出今天的標的
還有進場後完整的判斷邏輯
完全零元
但沒中明而有限
下方資訊欄有連結
每一個名單參加的場次
填完資料就報名完成了
畫面上這張圖
就是今天開盤跳空法的完整流程
截圖收藏起來
明天早上9點5分拿去對照
記得喔
只要少一個條件就整個跳過
換一打或是你今天不做
最後說一件事
上班族做當中最大的壓力
從來都不是技術
而是你用了你本來就不多的時間
卻換來一個不確定的結果
今天這個方法
其實想要把這件事情
變得更有依據
你花的每一分鐘
都應該花在值得看的地方
如果這支影片對你有幫助
歡迎分享給身邊也在學當中的朋友
我是摩卡
我們下部影片見